whether you love it or loathe it karaoke
is everywhere
in its birthplace of Japan there are
over 8 000 karaoke bars alone but have
you ever wondered where it came from
this is the story of karaoke and the
legendary man behind it
in 1968 in Osaka Japan Daisuke inoue was
working as a drummer at a cabaret Club
but money was tight and he was forced to
move back home with his parents in Kobe
he went looking for work in local bars
where house bands played instrumental
covers of the latest tunes for customers
to sing along to but they wanted a
keyboardist not a drummer
dice K couldn't read music so he learned
every song on the keyboard from memory
and soon became Kobe's go-to music guy
for his slow and easy Style
one day a businessman asked him a favor
he had an important client meeting he
wanted to end in a bar where he could
impress with his singing skills but dice
K was already booked
so his band recorded instrumental
versions of the man's favorite songs
onto an open Real tape recorder the
recorder was such a success that it
sparked an idea
with the help of an electronic shop dice
cake combined an amplifier with a
microphone a coin box and eight-track
car stereo
and aged 31 he invented the first ever
karaoke machine the Juke 8.
dice K took a bunch of Duke aids to
clubs in Kobe and before long their coin
boxes were overflowing
a year later Juke eights began to pop up
across the country continent and all
over the world
but he never patented his machine so
despite the billion dollar industry he's
created Daisuke inoue hasn't earned a
dime from the royalties he's just happy
he can say he brought Joy to the World
[Applause]
[Music]